I got to Harvard and heard about female identifying
students auditioning for the group as a form
of protest so I decided to do that just to
show them that they had this incredible range
of talent that they were totally ignoring.
They announced that they were going to let
women on cast and I remember sitting there
and just, my jaw dropping and being so excited.
I feel so lucky and so grateful to be one
of those first women, to be the first ever
black woman, it's so cool to be part of literally
the oldest theatrical group in the country
and to be part of a show that has a huge legacy.
To have everyone be so excited that we're
here, and wanting to watch us perform and
wanting to help us out and everything, has
been amazing and I think we're all so, we
feel incredibly grateful that we get to be
a part of it.